hey
hi everyone thanks for joining this talk
um i'm marina vidal
i'm really happy to be joining pi data
global 2020
and today i would like to talk to you
about um
how to proceed when you want to generate
more visual data
um simulating boosting augmenting
generating data
is definitely not something specific to
computer vision
and the best the approach that we're
going to take today
now um this particular problem
um is is even worse for vision
considering that we're in at an
age where um where everything is full of
cameras so there is a lot of
surveillance going on
and we know that um which at least
the only bright side of it would be that
once
you want to access that data to do
something good
about it um it could be easy
right it could be you should have plenty
of different
of of um of images of videos
you'd bring any kind of use case
considering that there's cameras for all
sorts of applications from industrial
surveillance to security and to
multiple sensors and vehicles in medical
diagnostics and everywhere basically
however um i just think that date has a
completely different story
it exists it's sitting plenty of times
it's sitting
um somewhere but
whether it be for very good reasons like
data privacy
or for simple or for other or for
actually
technical reasons or because there that
that
amount of data is not annotated and we
know it's it's extremely expensive in
the end to properly annotate your data
or maybe you do have annotations but
they measure completely different use
case
or perhaps um you you um
your use case at this time requiring a
different sensor which has a different
geometry to what you were expecting
whatever the case and plenty of times
once someone gives you data even if you
get access to it
it's not something you can use
immediately
and so of course this is not a new
problem
this has been going on for for ages um
and it's not particular
to deep learning on neural networks it
just is a bigger problem now
um now there are plenty of workarounds
that we've all used right so
um of course transfer learning is is the
first thing you
use um there's plenty of open data set
and at least that can give you
a start a head start and there's also
zero one few shot learning you try to
work with very with very little data um
but something also very intuitive is to
think well maybe i can simulate my own
maybe there is something that i can
that i can create um or at least that it
can
do to multiply the little data that i
have and that's what we're going to be
looking at today now um
let me share with you the assumptions
i'm making and a bit about me
and so we're all on the same page so i
work as i'm one of those people who has
suffered
um or backward later and i
typically work on the machine learning
and all computer vision
side of products and in the for the past
10 years it's been a mix of startups and
bigger corporates
from mostly med tech but then a bit of
entertainment and e-commerce startups
and more recently mobility
now what i'm assuming about you is that
you have a
perhaps a similar profile as in you're
interested or
are at least familiar with um
with machine learning or perhaps
computer vision
um that you've also suffered the lack of
data
perhaps it's the same pain points i have
sometimes
and that you're tempted to generate
europe and you're
curious to know how to proceed what
tools are out there
and that's exactly what this talk is
going to be about
what um what tools there are where
they fit where they can help where maybe
they can help that much
and the way um structuring it is
um of course it cannot be super
comprehensive
however um these are several tools that
i found fairly useful
and the way i'm going to to present them
today is
um is a good i found it a good approach
to structure them
um especially the approaches that i take
towards
problems and so i'm going to be talking
about
these techniques that you're seeing
around here
um and also think about them from the
perspective
of these purposes so at all times i'm
going to be thinking
and sharing with you could these fit in
a training
setting in a testing setting or perhaps
as an illustration
um right one other thought
and may all of these
in my point of view can be can be
somehow
put on a spectrum between um how close
they are
to the original real data
to how to to the unreal
virtual completely synthetic and
artificial domain which would be
about here and we'll see in a minute
why so let's start with augmentations
in this case i'm lumping together
classical augmentations
so the easiest thing that you can do is
perhaps play around with the
the intensity of your images the
contrast
um saturation and the like and
then another completely different family
of
augmentations are um adversarial and i'm
going to lump them in here
because um at their core they are adding
something to real data so you're
starting off with
real examples and you're doing something
to them
you're adding in for many of the methods
you're adding
perhaps some artifacts which are not
noise they are
targeted they have an intention and they
have a method to them
and but in the end it's adding something
the real data and in a way you're
creating
more samples similar to those initial
ones you had
to generate more data that you can use
either in training testing
um we'll see about that in a bit
now um there are quite a few open source
tools that you could
that you could start using you don't
need to go at it alone
but one thing you do need to think about
is of course
tools like pillow or opencv they can
take any image
and you can do all sorts of things to
that image but one thing
you need to remember is that typically
if you're in a within a machine learning
problem
unless it's an unsupervised problem
you're going to need annotations right
at some point
you're playing around with bounding
boxes or with the outlines with polygons
around the objects or the creatures that
you're interested in
and so one thing that these tools can do
for you
is at the same time that you're
augmenting and maybe rotating or
resizing or applying fine
transformations to
your images what they'll do is apply
the necessary uh transfer maintenance to
those undertakings as well
um i'm listing here a couple of tools
that i
encourage you to look into um of course
you can use them
they've got a python uh api
and of course if you don't want to you
can always
write your own using the usual virtual
conference
now moving on to the adversarial one so
typically
we've talked about adversarial attacks
in the past even at pi data
and and this this here
is the the most basic attack
i would say i think it was probably the
first one published
um if you want since this is the video
you can always pause it
and go look for the fast gradient method
um
and uh what you can what you will see is
at
its most basic this is about from a
model
that you know or that you suspect what
it is
you generate i think it's not exactly
noise you generate an
artifact but you can then overlay over
your initial image and that results
in a second image that is an adversarial
example
and that ideally even if your your
initial image was very clearly
identified as something like
a laptop once you've added that apparent
noise
it will be misclassified as something
else and
um you'll find that this does not only
apply to classification
this applies to many other use cases but
um let's not
dwell on that right now all i wanted to
share with you today is
that there are as well several
toolboxes that you can use and it would
make sense
to use them at least during your
training step
why because just like you you could do
with classical augmentations
um you're going to to want to have your
your vanilla training data
but you also want to generate plenty
more
of those that are slightly different
that are more challenging to the model
so that it gets used to
to extracting to learning what features
are really important to specific classes
right
and so this would look the setting can
easily look this way when you have your
your renewal training data you start
taking out um
different augmentations from with what
toolbox you've you've chosen
and you end up having the original data
but many many more
training samples that you can then use
to train your mod
now um it's up for discussion whether it
makes sense to use classical
augmentations
um at testing time i personally
prefer to stay as close as possible
to the real data that you're going to be
using
where perhaps your augmentations could
be adding some biases
um but definitely for adversarial
examples for adversarial augmentation so
to speak
it does make sense to add them to your
testing set
because um it stands to reason that well
it pays to be paranoid right of course
this depends on
how exposed you think of your product or
your company is going to be to such a
fact
but it doesn't hurt well
it could hurt depending on some there is
literature
describing how this might hurt accuracy
and so on
however um we can assume for the time
being that it doesn't hurt that much to
be paranoid
and to try to train your model to be
robust
to these kind of adverse stereotypes so
what you can do
is once you've already found your model
so let's assume you've had your training
data you obtained that data
we don't we don't know how right but
you've used it you've got it trained and
now it comes to time
you actually test it and what you would
probably want to do
is be able to know how ready you are
through adversarial attacks so what you
can do is just like before you get your
your adversarial toolbox you
have a hands or whatever and you start
applying
those attacks to your testing data so
that in the end you have a boosted or
unaugmented data set including those at
times
and of course once you test you're able
to say well
i i'm robust against attack x and y
but i'm failing at c um for uh
in with this five percentage
now um so recapping this a bit where
does this make sense
um a training time it definitely makes
sense to generate
um those examples that are very very
close to real data so that's why
on that spectrum that i was that i was
talking about at the beginning
and these would be very close to the
real side
um however with with specific
distortions
um to help your model learn better
features
and and then once you when you
start thinking about adversarial attacks
it makes sense to apply
these toolboxes these tools to both
training
and testing data and now a notes on
anonymization
um blurring pixelating um
popping out regions these are all
typical transformations typical um
typical augmentations right and these
can also be used
to to for instance erase people's faces
in fact it's a
really usual tool that uh that is being
used to anonymize data
certainly videos and images and so
these kind of augmentations also make
sense in the context of anonymization
um all right just another last note um
you you should think about what kind of
augmentations you're going to be
applying right
um so if we think about a toy data set
think about eminence
um what effect would rotating and
flipping
have on numbers like six nine
two five um so it stands to reason
that you need to take a look at what
kind of data set you have
um if it's a if you're dealing with
classes will be
will certain augmentations um hurt
exactly what you're trying to learn and
this doesn't only
apply to toy data right um in the case
of traffic signals
think that whenever there's arrows
you are going to very much care whether
a signal is flipped or not
okay so um moving on to generative
models
um there are plenty
today i'm going to be focusing on gas
and
a couple of families of old encoders
specifically sparse
and variational
and these i would place them
kind of in the middle of between real
and artificial
mostly because at their core um again
this could be a good time to pause the
video
and and for instance um if you're not
familiar already with them
um just check for for how gowns work
um and how encoders specifically
variational
and sparse work but regardless
of whether your training generates her
in an adversary manner
and explore what it's doing is you first
have to give it
a ton of data of the kind that you that
you want to create more of
so the model learns what that kind of
data looks like
and then it's at the second step once
it's learned it'll be ready
to create new samples that look very
similar to those that it learned before
so in a way it is generating new data
but it should be ideally it should be
extremely close to that distribution
that it learned at the beginning
now i'm just going to give you a couple
of examples one of these use cases
can be you to simulate environmental
conditions
so some very impressive results came out
of
of um certain papers so i'm listing them
here um
and if you want to play around there's
there's also repos where you can clear
up with these
and and these impressive results of
everything
dealt with for instance translating
between
summer and winter day and night and
maybe
sunny weather and and rain and it can be
extremely easy
uh not extremely easy it's gonna be
useful to
for instance when you're at the time of
training um
when you have perhaps only data that
pertains to a specific time of the year
or specific time of the day
to have the exact same scenario but with
different environmental conditions
that this is not exactly new so you can
see the dates of these papers
but it can be extremely useful still
now another application of
of these kind of models and is interface
generations and
you can imagine now that that here
anonymization is a
really immediate use case that comes to
mind right um
now these two papers um well this image
right here is
um comes from the privacy this one i
generated of course this is not the real
one this is the real galaxy but of
course
cube was not sharing video time with me
at all
um you can you can find so this this
came
from um from code and a model already
trained
from this paper the first order motion
model for image
animation um and basically
again these models so they work
differently
but again they start from real images
and in one case they are generating
a face that just that does not exist but
that somehow recreates
features that existed in the original
data
and in this second case what it's doing
is applying
specific um specific motion vectors
were to face which is real so this was
originally
um a real photograph what
is not real is that this person
was doing these exactly they didn't
following the movements that i was doing
right
now i'm listening here a couple of repos
that you might be
interested in in trying out as well one
thing
i would like to point out is these
methods um
you you really need to think about why
you want to generate your data
and what you're going to be using it for
mostly because you will notice that
there are mistakes right so
this is not a mature technology there's
nothing wrong with that
it will it can already be extremely
useful
for certain applications um but if we're
thinking about generating training data
or testing data we need to be aware of
its
current limitations so consider that for
instance you can tell
that this model has seen an initial data
set that where there were people with
glasses right
and if you pay close attention you'll
see how um
since every frame is generated
independently
some of those frames show and show a
glass social glasses
whereas others don't so there are
inconsistencies
for many use cases this is what this
won't be a problem
for others um well you put so
again as as with augmentations you just
have to pause and think okay what am i
going to be doing with this data
do i care about textures do i care that
there are inconsistencies between frames
do i care that perhaps um at the borders
you
if you again if you if you zoom in you
would see
oh in fact it's quite apparent even if
you don't zoom in
there are certain blurred parts there
are some artifacts that are noticeable
and you can see it in the other concept
here you can definitely see it
the way where there's we try to find the
the limits of it looking left and right
and you can see that the model isn't
quite ready
for those fixed pain movements but
perhaps for you
in a use case that is not a problem
right so i was already mentioning some
of these issues
um by the way one of the most
successful paper sagas or technology
sagas lately
has been style guns from from nvidia um
and one of the of uh of the best
applications is to generate more samples
of specific objective theme at training
time
so for instance cars for instance
faith's train on the celebrity
data set and the limitations that this
approach has
in any case is that you still need data
so if you think about it
we started the beginning of this talk we
started with the problem that
we don't have this well if your problem
was that you didn't have annotations
then these kind of of techniques can
help you
what where they won't help you is to
generate
that initial data because you're still
going to unless you're you're dealing
with faces and you can use an open data
set
um you're going to need you're going to
need that initial data
to train your generative model
the second limitation is that
they tend to need those objects to be
perfectly aligned
um and you can actually see it and and
by the way the images that
they produce tend to be fairly small so
they tend to be
this is the most typical um this is
going to be
more frequent than big scenes big
complex scenes
this is improving and every time there's
a new style gun
the resolution has improved um but you
can still
foresee these artifacts in this image
you can see how perfect
the the main object is whereas
the car sitting beside it shows
among the fact that any human would
notice are just
they're just for you same thing happens
with
uh with these kind of faces and if in
fact if you go to
um there's this this website called this
person does not exist
all of those images all of those faces
come from
from the papers from this group at
intermedia
um you will see that every every once in
a while you get
one of one of these faces with artifacts
and it is like a bit nightmarish
it's it's actually fun so you should
take a look
um right other problems that you might
find is um future disentanglement i
wanted to
point this out so um because this might
take
this is also a point where you need to
spend some effort
other than filtering out failures like
this one
um there's a program that has been
worked on recently and it's and it's
quite improved
and um it's about when you're generating
these new images
are you able to say generate
a similar image to what you saw at
training time
um a face like this one but i want a
different
hair color or i want this person to this
new person to have glasses
or a mustache or or whatever
and that is extremely quickly um
recently there's been a lot of other
advancements
um and specifically again this this
group from nvidia has been publishing a
lot
um and you can see some applications for
instance in things like
i want the same person with bangs or
wavy hair
or uh or going on um
and if you think about it this requires
some control
over how the features are represented in
latent space being able to
somehow um tap into a specific feature
in latent space over when
so that when the when it goes back to
image space
um the feature that you wanted is the
one that's been sampled and that's been
used to recreate this movement
so again the most the the most
immediate use case here is actually for
privacy
and an imitation so deep fates have had
really really bad press um and they are
dangerous it's
it's better that we all are aware that
they exist so that we can
um doubt whenever we receive certain
videos um
just you know just hold and think
whether they might be
fake um but there is a bright side to
them
and that's they they have huge potential
um to enable people to tap into data
that they otherwise
should not be allowed to touch and
so in the in the space of anonymization
they have a
there's a huge potential and
of course once you've considered the
caveats that i was talking about
and filtering out failures or or whether
certain features that are reproduced
don't exactly potentially harm your
training data
if once you've established that those
don't matter that much for your
particular use case
um narrative models can help a lot in
in terms of creating more technical
now um to to finish um
i would like to touch the most
artificial slash synthetic slash virtual
data that you can generate when we talk
about simulation
we typically talk about game engines
that are now used
also to create worlds um where you can
test this them
so um a very now we there's
actually there's a corner challenge and
that you can see results of
um and and this these kind of tools are
very useful
if for instance you're trying to test a
full system that um
that maybe is trying to learn how to
drive so maybe you have a reinforcements
a reinforcement learning system that
that has to learn whether to
turn left right accelerate brake and
in for that being able to create maps
and create situations with other agents
that could collide
those are extremely useful and as you
can see
um the realism is is um it's fairly nice
it's not it's not
um that's not perfect but but it looks
really good
and they don't only give you rgb data
they they can only give you up
as well so um examples of this
are as i was saying carla you also have
airsim
but there's a there's a list of um of
simulators that you can use
um some of them are based on a real
engine some of them are are unity based
and what i would like to point out here
is
that as i was saying if what you're
trying to
to to um to test um
or is it's actually it's a it's a full
system um that is trying to learn
how to operate in one of these worlds
these simulations can be extremely
useful
but again as was the case with
augmentations
of generative models you have to think
whether
what you're going to be generating
can hurt the actual thing that you're
trying to learn
um for instance if what you're going to
if what you're trying to learn
is to detect is to detect
people um for a specific sensor
so maybe one of these specific boxes
perhaps using images
that are so perfect because they didn't
actually come from a sensor even though
these are modeled on
sensors and they are not the real
sensors right so there is going to be
what we call a domain gap between those
the real images that you will be getting
from your sensor and what
is being simulated you need to think
which part of all of this is is
what your is your focus are you going to
be training the full thing and then it
makes sense to have a simulated world
or were you interested in in say a
perception system
and then perhaps um that difference
between what's real and what's
artificial
might hurt you okay
so um just have a quick recap and we've
seen
a few techniques that can help you
either
multiply the real data that you do have
or generate completely new data that
with different degrees of of realism
um remember to think about
whether the images that you're
generating
can somehow mess with what you're
learning or not so
it's not a there's no golden solution
that can solve the problem for you
um and at least what you
have now from from this presentation is
a list of tools that you can go out
and use all of them have python apis
that you can use
um and so all i can say now is
have fun and i hope to get a ton of
questions comments um at the q a
during the event otherwise keep in touch
and stay safe bye